.
Ich würde ihr so gerne
Tanzen beibringen -
Salsa, Merengue.
Ja, das sehen wir dann noch.
Wenn wir in einer Extremsituation
sind und einen Konflikt haben,
dann explodiert sie schnell.
Aber ich beruhige mich
schnell wieder.
Ja, ja, das stimmt.
Über was ich mich aufrege?
Unwichtige Kleinigkeiten,
worüber sich die meisten aufregen:
einen offenen WC-Deckel.
Es ist immer ihre Schuld.
- Ja.
Ich sagte immer zu Gott, ich will
keinen typischen Ecuadorianer,
keinen Frauenhelden.
So einen will ich nicht.
Dann kam er - ein gutes Zeichen.
# Forever you and me ...
* Pulsierende Klänge *
* Entspannter Salsarhythmus *
Manchmal braucht eine Liebesbeziehung
einen zweiten Anlauf,
damit es richtig funktioniert.
Bei diesem Paar, das ich
gleich treffe, war es genau so.
Einerseits lag zwischen ihnen die
halbe Welt - das ist sehr schwierig -
andererseits
brach für ihn "eine Welt zusammen",
als es zum ersten Date kam.
Wir sind in Ecuador
an der Pazifikküste.
Hier bin ich mit Tom Friedli
und Angie Suárez
zu einer Bootsfahrt verabredet.
Hello. Hola.
Ich hoffe, sie wollen nicht
mit diesem hier mit mir herausfahren.
Die Schweizer
erkennt man am Kuh-Gurt.
Tom, ich freue mich sehr,
schön, dich kennenzulernen.
Ich bin kein Heimweh-Schweizer,
aber ich trage gerne
Sachen aus der Schweiz.
Willkommen in Ecuador.
Soy Mona.
- Mi esposa, Angie.
Hola.
- Encantada.
El gusto es mio.
- Angie.
* Tuckern *
Mit dabei ist die zehnjährige Carla.
Es gibt nichts Schlimmeres,
als wenn sich die Eltern küssen.
Schrecklich.
- Sie geht immer dazwischen.
Eifersüchtig.
- Selber eifersüchtig.
Wie begann eigentlich
eure gemeinsame Geschichte?
Unsere Geschichte ...
* Er wiederholt es auf Spanisch. *
Angie?
Ich habe an der Universität
studiert, das war ...
... 2009?
Ungefähr 2008.
Ich war immer in der Bibliothek
mit einer Freundin.
Sie zeigte mir eine Dating-Website
und sagte:
"Schau, willst diesem Mann nicht
einmal schreiben? Er ist hübsch."
Diese Dating-Plattform -
ich bin ein Latinofreund -
war sehr
auf Südamerika spezialisiert.
Ich war überzeugt, wenn es mit ihr
so gut geht wie beim Chatten,
dann wird sie meine Frau werden.
Aber als Tom Angie nach einiger Zeit
nach einem ersten Date fragte,
fiel er aus allen Wolken.
Sie sagte,
dass sie mir etwas sagen müsse:
Sie war schwanger.
Was hat er gesagt?- Ich habe
gesagt, dass du schwanger warst.
Für mich brach eine Welt zusammen.
Also eine Welt ...
Für mich platzte ein Traum.
Trotzdem besuchte er sie
auf seiner Lateinamerika-Reise.
2011 war Angie
hochschwanger im Spital.
Ich kam mit meinem Blumenstrauss
und einer Karte herein.
Zu unserem ersten Date.
Und sie lag dort
in ihrem Spital-Nachthemd.
Nicht zurechtgemacht wie jetzt.
Aber so war es eben.
Tom vergass Angie nie ganz.
Vier Jahre und eine Scheidung später
reiste er wieder nach Ecuador.
Zuerst war es nur Freundschaft,
aber dann realisierte ich,
dass er sehr liebevoll ist,
einen ausgeprägten Familiensinn hat.
Er ist ein sehr spezieller Mann.
Ich sagte mir:
"So einem wirst du
nie mehr begegnen."
Bei dieser Frau
war es einfach ihre ...
...  Selbstständigkeit,
die sie hatte.
Sie hat mich einfach fasziniert.
Und einfach ihre Schönheit.
Dabei hasst er es, wenn ich mich
schminke, aber ich tue es trotzdem.
* Fröhliche Salsaklänge *
Wenn du Freunden erzählst,
dass du einen Ausländer heiratest,
stellen sie viele Fragen:
"Hat er ein Auto?
Schenkt er dir eine Wohnung?"
"Wie viel Geld hat er?
Was hat er für einen Job?"
Aber ich weiss, diesen Druck
gibst du mir nicht weiter.
Da sind wir wirklich anders.
* Asiatisch anmutende Klänge *
Ich ziehe die Schuhe an.
Ich auch, ich halte das.
In Wuxi sind Matthias und Sharon
schon lange wach.
Auf dem Weihnachtsmarkt
verkaufen sie ihre selbstgebackenen
Brote und Zöpfe.
Dabei werden sie unterstützt.
Es gibt genügend Platz.
Cheng Yi,
du fährst mit diesem Auto mit.
Wir sind gut in der Zeit.
Besser als letztes Jahr.
- Hoffentlich.
Gehst du bitte etwas zur Seite?
Wir müssen da durch.
Im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr
haben wir mehr Brot produziert.
* Sharon lacht. *
Ich bin viel ruhiger als Sharon.
Aber sie muss alles auf Chinesisch
organisieren, das stresst sie.
Sie muss Fragen beantworten,
alles koordinieren.
Ich bin da viel ruhiger.
Okay, let's go.
Auch den kleinen Jonathan
bringt nichts aus der Ruhe.
Er schlägt dem Vater nach.
Sharon und Mathias
leben im Expat-Quartier von Wuxi,
in Venice Garden.
In ihrer Hobbybäckerei ist Sharon
für die Bestellungen zuständig,
Mathias backt das Brot,
neben seinem 100-%-Job
bei einer Schweizer Firma.
Die meisten unserer Bekannten
unterstützen uns gerne.
V.a. dich mögen sie,
du hast mit ihnen Kontakt.
Ich halte mich eher im Hintergrund,
wo ich hart arbeite.
Bäcker Mathias.
* Fröhliche Instrumentalversion
von "Take my Hand" *
* Sharon spricht chinesisch. *
Dieser Weihnachtsmarkt ist speziell,
weil dieses Fest in China
eigentlich gar keine Tradition hat.
Jeder hat seinen Bereich.
- Ja.
Chinese here.
Ich bin im Hintergrund und du vorne.
Danke für die Schweizer Flaggen,
nicht nur chinesische.
Thank you.
Sharon ist im Element.
Ich habe Sharon-Kräfte.
Sharon-Kräfte, ja.
Die bekommst du oft zu spüren.
- Ja, deine positive Energie.
Babsie, wir machen das anders.
Darf ich einen? Ich bin so hungrig.
- Ja, nimm!
Wie viel?
Du musst mich lebenslang ertragen.
Das ist ein hoher Preis.
- Ah, okay.
* Sharon lacht. *
Was mir an Latinas gefällt?
Mir gefällt die braune Haut,
die schwarzen Haare.
Er mag Frauen mit Kurven.
Ja, gut.
Ja, also, und ich mag sehr gerne
gut gebaute Frauen.
Angie und Tom kamen 2015 zusammen.
Nach drei Jahren Fernbeziehung
zog Tom nach Ecuador.
Ein Jahr später
kauften sie dieses Hotel in Canoa.
Direkt am Meer.
Hm?
Morgen.
- Morgen, Mona.
Bei dir geht's früh los.
Wenn ich es vergleiche:
Am Morgen um 8 Uhr
ein Sales-Meeting zu haben
oder hier den Hof zu kehren
und aufs Meer schauen -
da ziehe ich es vor,
hier den Hof zu kehren.
Die Krawatte und den Anzug
hast du an den Nagel gehängt?
Ich habe noch zwei, drei zu Hause.
Aber ich vermisse sie
überhaupt nicht.
Aber es ist krass:
Du hast dein komplettes, altes Leben
für die Liebe aufgegeben,
damit du mit Angie
zusammen sein kannst?
Nach drei Jahren Fernbeziehung
mussten wir entscheiden,
ob Angie in die Schweiz kommt
oder ich nach Ecuador gehe.
Angie gab mir den Kick,
das zu machen.
Ich war 50 und sagte mir:
Jetzt war ich bis 50 bei der Bank,
jetzt möchte ich noch
etwas Richtiges im Leben machen.
Und habe ein Hotel eröffnet.
So habe ich es gesagt.
Und alle sagten, dass du spinnst?
- Äh ...
Ja. Viele.
Bereiten wir das Frühstück vor.
* Donnergrollen *
Jetzt regnet es.
Das Wetter ist ganz schlimm,
also wirklich.
Es ist keine Schweizer Küche,
aber ...
Tom bereitet das Frühstück
für seine Familie vor.
Carlita macht noch Hausaufgaben.
Das ist ihr Zimmer.
Ihr wohnt ...
Also ihr wohnt wirklich hier?
- Ja.
Das habe ich nicht geschnallt, ich
dachte, das sei die Küche vom Hotel.
Aber das ist eure Wohnung?
- Ja.
Das gemeinsame Schlafzimmer
ist direkt hinter der Rezeption.
Bueno?
- Ja, komm.
Hier bewahre ich meine Schätze auf:
Das hier ist die spezielle Karte,
die mir Thomas
im Spital geschenkt hat.
No!
- Si.
Er hat geschrieben: "Ich weiss
nicht, was ich schenken soll,
darum lege ich 30 ¤ bei."
"Kauf dem Baby etwas Schönes."
"Sag ihm, es käme
von seinem Onkel aus der Schweiz."
Oh.
"Eine feste Umarmung
und einen dicken Kuss."
Ich hüte sie wie einen Schatz.
Ich muss sagen, Thomas ist immer
sehr aufmerksam und zärtlich.
Diese Karte hängt hier,
wo ich all meine wertvollen
Erinnerungen aufbewahre.
Okay.
* Fröhliche Salsaklänge *
Hier reisten wir in die Schweiz.
Das ist meine Tochter.
Tom wollte schauen,
ob es uns dort gefällt.
Ich ging mit,
aber am Schluss sagte ich Nein.
Hier in Ecuador
habe ich meine klaren Aufgaben:
Ich bin Mutter, Ehefrau,
ich arbeite,
verdiene mein eigenes Geld,
ich bin in der Nähe meiner Familie.
Wir bleiben hier,
mir gefällt das Strandleben.
* Schneller Salsarhythmus *
In einem Hotel mit 15 Zimmern
und drei Angestellten
geht die Arbeit nie aus.
Im Moment sind sie ausgebucht,
obwohl das Wetter für ecuadorianische
Verhältnisse nicht gut ist.
Wow, okay.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine andere Art
der Zubereitung von Kochbananen.
Kochbananen mit Erdnuss.
Ich mag sehr gerne Erdnuss.
Manabí, die Provinz, in der wir
leben, ist die Erdnuss-Provinz.
Nach so einem Bollen
hat man gegessen.
Mmh.
- Das ist definitiv so.
Wenn ich das esse, habe ich bis
nachmittags um 15 Uhr keinen Hunger.
Schmeckt es, Carlita?
Nimm noch eine Erdbeere.
Wie reagierten deine Eltern,
als du sagtest,
dass du in Ecuador lebst
und dort eine Frau und ein Kind hast?
Angie war nicht die erste Frau,
die ich meinen Eltern vorstellte.
Sie sind daran gewöhnt,
schon wieder eine.
Die 15.
Du wirst rot.
Das ist mir etwas peinlich.
Ich war von allen die Beste.
Ich habe die Beste!
Und du bist auch glücklich mit mir?
Ich habe ihm immer gesagt, dass
ich noch gerne einen Sohn hätte.
Einen kleinen Prinzen.
Ich habe mir immer vorgestellt,
dass er so wie er wäre.
Immer wenn ich ihn mit Kindern sehe,
sage ich ihm,
du wärst ein grossartiger Vater.
Aber okay.
Ich liebe Kinder.
Nächstes Jahr werde ich 52.
Wenn das Kind zehn Jahre alt ist,
bin ich 62.
Wir haben ja ein Kind.
* Fröhliche Klänge *
Ich sage ihr die ganze Zeit,
dass ich sie liebe.
Und wenn ich das sage,
dann meine ich alles an ihr.
Aber am meisten mag ich,
wie freundlich sie zu allen ist,
zu jedem Menschen, jedem Tier,
sogar zu fiesen Menschen.
Sie ist wirklich nett,
sie ist ein guter Mensch.
Sie ist einfach zu viel für mich.
Andrea und Pedro haben sich in der
ältesten Kolonialstadt Südamerikas
kennengelernt,
in Santa Marta in Kolumbien.
Andrea nahm eine Auszeit,
um durch Südamerika zu reisen.
Pedro war ihr Tourguide.
Ihr erstes Gespräch
drehte sich um Schweizer Schokolade,
die mag Pedro
fast so gerne wie Andrea.
Ich mag Schweizer Schokolade,
ich liebe sie.
Andrea sagte, die beste Schokolade
käme aus der Schweiz.
Und ich meinte, ja, die beste
Schokolade mit dem weltbesten Kakao
aus meiner Heimat Venezuela.
Das war unser erstes Gespräch.
Ein paar Monate später
wurden sie ein Paar.
Damit sie zusammenleben können,
müssen sie heiraten.
Seit Monaten versuchen sie,
die nötigen Dokumente zu bekommen.
Immer fehlte etwas.
Mit Skype und Briefen
überbrücken sie diese Zeit.
Wir sind beide davon überzeugt, dass
uns Schwierigkeiten stärker machen.
Das hat sie auch im Brief
geschrieben.
Wenn ich allein bin,
dann denke ich zu viel nach.
Wenn wir zusammen sind,
spreche ich über meine Gefühle.
Ich vermisse sie sehr.
Die Unterlagen für ein Visum,
um in der Schweiz zu heiraten,
reichte Pedro
bei der Botschaft in Bogotá ein.
Sie haben noch keine Antwort.
In seiner Heimat Venezuela
arbeitete Pedro als Polizist.
Wegen wirtschaftlicher Probleme in
seinem Land ging er nach Kolumbien.
Hier ist er Übersetzer für Touristen.
Una cordial bienvenida
a la cuidad Santa Martin,
por supuesto al tour de la ciudad.
Im Namen der Agentur
heissen wir euch herzlich willkommen
in Santa Marta und auf dem Trekking
in die Verlorene Stadt,
die Ciudad Perdida.
Diese Wanderung in die Verlorene
Stadt buchte Andrea damals auch.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass ich die Liebe meines Lebens
auf einer Tour finde.
* Abenteuerliche Klänge *
Pedro geht gerne
auf die viertägigen Touren.
Bei der Wanderung durch den Regenwald
vergisst er den ganzen Papierkrieg.
Die Ciudad Perdida
ist eine der grössten,
wiederentdeckten antiken Städte
Südamerikas.
Ein ganz spezieller Ort.
In der Schweiz wartet Andrea.
Ihr Vater unterstützt sie.
Othmar Götz unterrichtet Deutsch
für Einwanderinnen und Einwanderer.
Er kennt die Schwierigkeiten
von binationalen Paaren.
Ich mochte ihn sofort,
ein guter Typ.
Die Herausforderung ist,
möglichst
schnell gut Deutsch zu lernen.
Eine gute Basis zu haben.
Dann hat er viel schneller
bessere Chancen.
Das ist auch
eine Herausforderung für sie,
sie darf nicht dauernd Englisch
mit ihm reden.
Es entsteht vielleicht
ein Ungleichgewicht:
Der eine hat hier einen Job,
eine Familie und kennt sich aus,
der andere hat gar nichts. Das
ist für eine Beziehung nicht einfach.
Jemand, der aus solchen
Verhältnissen wie er kommt,
was er schon alles durchgemacht hat,
er hat sich hochgearbeitet.
Dann weiss man, dass man es auch
von ganz unten schaffen kann.
Am Anfang
müssen wir beide einstecken.
Man muss sich reinknien,
mit Enttäuschungen umgehen können,
und nicht aufgeben.
Aber du auch. Ihr beide werdet ...
Die strenge Zeit hört nicht auf,
nur weil ihr verheiratet seid.
Nein, man ist dann einfach
gemeinsam im gleichen Land.
Es braucht auch Mut,
diesen Schritt zu wagen.
Mut.
- Ja.
Das braucht es.
Er kommt dann automatisch.
Wir sind gespannt.
- Ich auch.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Der Weihnachtsmarkt von Wuxi ist eine
Attraktion, auch für viele Expats.
An Sharons und Mathias' Stand
läuft das Geschäft.
* Sie sprechen chinesisch. *
Die Kundin will Followerin werden.
Sie meint, in Wuxi sei solches
selbstgebackenes Brot selten.
Jetzt haben wir schon
über 200 Kunden in der Bäckerei.
Wohoo.
Wie viel?
- Focus.
15. Ist die Portion zu gross?
Nein, 16 ist gut.- Ich kann
die erste Portion probieren.
Warte, warte, warte.
- Okay.
Sharon und Mathias unterscheiden sich
nicht nur im Temperament,
sondern auch in der Arbeitsweise.
Das Schild
schützt die Brötchen dahinter.
* Sie singt ein langsames,
chinesisches Lied. *
Sharons Mutter
singt für Jonathan ein Schlaflied,
von einer Schwalbe,
die den Frühling bringt.
Hallo Dylan, lange nicht gesehen.
Rosinen oder Cranberry?
Lass mich das machen, Babsie.
Hier, bitte.
(Mann) Thank you. One, two.
Heiss, heiss! Aufwärmen!
Der Müll gehört nach draussen.
Relax.
Wir sind ein Team.
Diese zwei Wörter, wenn er die sagt:
"relax" und "beeil dich".
Das treibt sie zur Weissglut.
Sie ist halt so energiegeladen,
impulsiv.
Aktiv.
Sie ist ganz anders als ich.
Deshalb habe ich sie geheiratet,
um den Kreis zu schliessen.
Küss mich. Nein.
Ja, sie ist anders.
* Asiatisch anmutende Version
von "Take my Hand" *
Jonathan, es ist alles gut.
Noch vor dem Mittag
haben sie das ganze Brot verkauft.
Babsie, gut gemacht.
Ui, ui, ui, ui.
Gib deinem Söhnchen einen Kuss.
Wir haben's so gut gemacht.
- Yes.
Weinst du?
Du hast es
so gut gemacht, wie immer.
Hör auf zu weinen,
sonst muss ich auch.
* Ruhige Klänge *
* Pulsierende Klänge *
Eines Tages fragte ich sie,
ob sie gerne Grossmutter wäre,
und sie sagte Ja, aber in den USA
sei das nicht möglich.
Also schlug ich ihr vor,
in die Schweiz zu ziehen.
"Würdest du das für mich tun?"
Ich sagte:
"Dasselbe hast du für mich getan."
* Gemütliche Country-Klänge *
Jay ist Native American.
Mit Brigitte lebte er zehn Jahre
in Montana in einem Reservat.
Vor zwei Wochen
zog er nach Langenthal.
Hier wollen sie
ihren Lebensabend verbringen.
Aber der Neuanfang wird von
seiner Krebserkrankung überschattet.
Das riecht wunderbar, was machst du?
Du kennst das,
wir hatten das schon mal.
Ah ja, diese Käsedinger.
Käseküchlein, wir geben
noch etwas Speck dazu, gute Idee.
Wir erfinden ein neues Gericht
und werden berühmt.
* Jay lacht. *
Schuhe weg. Brille weg.
Das machen wir jeden Morgen.
Wir sagen Danke für alles,
was wir bis jetzt bekommen haben.
Weil bis jetzt alles
eigentlich gut geklappt hat.
Jay lebte noch nie
ausserhalb der USA:
In der neuen Umgebung
ist das Räucherritual
auch ein Stück Heimat für ihn.
Nach wenigen Tagen realisierte ich:
Es funktioniert hier auch,
auch emotional.
Wir ziehen die Schuhe aus
wie in einem Tipi
und verbinden uns mit Mutter Erde.
* Er murmelt auf Englisch. *
Wie isst man die Dinger?
En Guete.
- Guete.
Jays Krankheit
ist ein grosses Thema in ihrem Leben.
Wie es weitergeht, hängt von ihr ab.
Mein Darm ist jetzt krebsfrei.
Sie haben 60 cm rausgeschnitten.
Aber die Lymphknoten sind befallen.
Der Arzt in den USA meinte,
wenn es so bleibe,
müsse ich eine Chemotherapie machen.
Dann sollte es okay sein.
Wenn der Krebs aber streut -
und das beschäftigt mich -
habe ich ein grosses Problem.
Gehen wir?
Nicht nur die Krankheit
beschäftigt Jay.
Auch das Einleben
in der neuen Umgebung
ist für den 68-Jährigen
nicht einfach.
Ich hatte mein Leben lang
eine Wohnung, Autos, Motorräder,
die mir gehörten.
Nun miete ich alles,
lebe in einem fremden Land,
verstehe die Sprache
und das Gelesene nicht.
Ich glaube,
ich muss mein Leben überdenken.
Für Jay, aber auch für Brigitte
ist das alles eine grosse Belastung.
Sie fühlt sich verantwortlich,
dass es ihrem Mann
in der Schweiz gut geht.
Er mag Schnee.
Er sieht ihn jetzt jeden Tag.
Der junge Hund Okona,
den sie aus Montana mitbrachten,
ist eine gute Ablenkung.
- (Beide) Good boy.
Ich habe Gottvertrauen,
dass es so kommt, wie es muss.
Dass jetzt nicht alles
nach hinten losgeht.
Es ist eine Bewährungsprobe für uns.
und unsere Beziehung.
Ich mache mir keine Sorgen.
Meine Familie schon.
Ich gebe acht, der Schöpfer
hat uns hierher geführt.
aber nicht zum Sterben.
Oh!
Wie ein dicker Fisch an der Angel.
Come here.
Come on, boy.
Good boy, look at you run.
Come on.
* Ruhige Klänge *
* Pulsieren *
Meine Tochter Carla
brauchte einen Vater,
ich konnte das nicht für sie sein,
auch wenn ich es mit meiner
ganzen Kraft versucht habe.
Ich musste zuerst die Tochter
fast überzeugen,
dass ich jetzt die richtige Person
bin im Leben der beiden.
Dass wir beide uns verstehen.
Als die Mutter das sah,
schaute sie auch mich anders an.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Auch,
wenn es ein paar Umwege brauchte:
Angie und Tom haben zusammengefunden
und sich an der Pazifikküste
von Ecuador ein Zuhause aufgebaut.
Also Carla, hast du alles bereit,
um es abzugeben? Lass mich sehen.
Das ist Mathematik.
- Okay, und sonst?
Geschichte.
- Okay.
Okay.
In dieser Hinsicht
bin ich etwas tougher als Angie.
Sie weiss, dass sie etwas machen
muss, wenn ich es sage.
Wenn Angie es sagt,
hat sie noch etwas Spielraum.
Bei Mathematik und Englisch
bin ich hinterher.
Angie kümmert sich ums andere.
Okay.
Ich habe alles gemacht,
was uns der Lehrer aufgetragen hat.
Tun wir es in die Tasche
und bringen es dem Lehrer.
Carla hat noch immer Homeschooling.
Ihre Hausaufgaben muss sie aber
regelmässig in der Schule abgeben.
Ein funktionierendes Internet
haben hier nicht alle.
Das hier ist ihre Schule.
- Das dort?
Ist das eine öffentliche Schule?
- Das ist eine Privatschule.
Muss man das?- Es ist sicher besser
als die öffentliche Schule.
Aber es ist die einzige,
die wir hier im Dorf haben.
Guten Tag, Herr Lehrer,
wie geht es Ihnen?
Gut und Ihnen?
Geben wir die Hausaufgaben hier ab?
- Ja.
Ich hoffe, alles ist in Ordnung.
Oh, nein, ich habe etwas vergessen.
Mir und dem Englischlehrer
musst du zwei abgeben.
Jetzt hat sie
wieder etwas vergessen.
Wir müssen noch zwei Kopien machen?
Ja zwei. Und hier müssen Sie
ihre Tochter beurteilen,
wie sie ihre Hausaufgaben macht.
Macht sie sie gerne, macht sie sie
zuverlässig oder gar nicht.
Was schreiben wir hier?
Sehr zufriedenstellend,
zufriedenstellend,
verbesserungsfähig.
Unge... Was heisst das?
Ungenügend.
Was ist das Fazit?
Satisfact... Zufriedenstellend.
Sehr zufriedenstellend.
Hach.
Sa...
...tis...
...fac...
...torio.
Cha, cha, cha, cha ... vamos.
Gracias.
- Bis Dienstag.
* Bellen *
* Fröhliche Klänge *
Bevor Angie ein Hotel führte,
war sie Journalistin.
Und sie hat noch
ganz andere Ambitionen.
Darf ich dich stören?
Ja, klar.
- Was machst du?
Ich lerne.
Ich mache Onlineunterricht.
- Okay.
Das ist meine zweite Ausbildung,
ich studiere Rechtswissenschaft.
Jus?
- Ja, Anwältin.
Was ist dein Ziel?
Ich möchte gerne eines Tages
eine kleine Kanzlei haben.
So kann ich den Leuten helfen,
damit sie ihre Rechte kennen.
Wenn ich mich
mit dem Recht auskenne,
ist das auch hilfreich
für meine Arbeit im Tourismus.
Angie ist in bescheidenen
Verhältnissen aufgewachsen.
Schon als Kind wollte sie lernen
und etwas erreichen, erzählt sie mir.
Guten Tag, wie geht's?
In der Nähe von Canoa
gehört Tom ein grosses Stück Land.
Einer seiner Arbeiter
lebt hier mit seiner Familie.
Uhaa.
Wenn er auf seiner Finca unterwegs
ist, erinnert sich Tom an früher.
Meine Mutter
wuchs auf einem Bauernhof auf.
Während der Schulzeit
half ich meinem Onkel
mindestens zweimal zwei Wochen
pro Jahr auf dem Hof.
Ich wollte eigentlich Bauer werden.
Das war mein Wunsch.
Meine Eltern sagten aber immer,
dass ein Bauer keine Zukunft habe.
Als ich dann hier war, dachte ich,
dass ich doch noch Bauer werde.
Halt nicht mit 16, sondern mit 50.
Vamos.
Wisst ihr, wo sie arbeiten?
Im Sumpfgebiet.
- Wo ist das?
Irgendwo auf den 38 ha
reparieren Landarbeiter den Zaun.
Für die Finca zahlte Tom 60'000 ¤.
Hier will er
einmal Drachenfrüchte anbauen,
um sie nach Nordamerika
zu exportieren.
Arbeiten sie wirklich hier?
- Ja, im Sumpf.
Aber wo ist das?
Ich habe vorher
die Motorsäge gehört,
vielleicht sind sie dort drüben.
* Entspannte Gitarrenklänge *
* Weiter entfernt
heult eine Motorsäge auf. *
Gracias.
Im letzten Moment
habe ich sie gefunden.
Das sind meine Angestellten.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, gut.
Vielen Dank euch allen.
Ich bezahle euch jetzt,
damit ihr entspannt
ins Wochenende gehen könnt.
* Tom lacht. *
60, und fünf.
- Vielen Dank.
Hier auch.
Sind wir quitt?
- Ja.
Hast du keine Angst, Mathias?
Schau Thomas, das ist mein 4x4.
-Claro.
Cuidense, buen fin de semana.
Die Finca soll auch ein Rückzugsort
für ihn und Angie sein,
wenn sie einmal nicht mehr arbeiten.
Aber es gibt noch ein Problem
mit dem Wegrecht.
Das möchte Tom
bei einer Notarin klären.
Hier steht,
das sei ein öffentlicher Weg.
Das ist für Sie.
Y también por aca una firma.
Es hilft, dass sich Angie
in Rechtsfragen auskennt.
Das ist sehr technisches Spanisch.
Deshalb soll sie es durchlesen.
Wenn sie sagt, dass es gut ist,
passt es für mich. Ich vertraue ihr.
Der Vertrag soll garantieren,
dass sie auch in Zukunft
freien Zugang zur Finca haben
und keine bösen Überraschungen
erleben.
Es fehlt nur noch die Unterschrift.
* Sie spricht spanisch. *
Como el clima, no?
* Tom lacht. *
* Sie spricht spanisch. *
* Pulsieren *
Auch bei Andrea und Pedro
dreht sich alles
um ein wichtiges Dokument.
Heute ist Weihnachten, und das
ist das beste Weihnachtsgeschenk.
24. Dezember.
Er war heute in der Post.
Das Visum zur Einreise ist da.
Wir können hier heiraten.
Vor einer Woche
gab ich den letzten Brief
persönlich beim Migrationsamt ab.
Ich fragte,
wie lange das in etwa dauert.
Man weiss es nicht,
es ist alles immer ungewiss,
man kann nichts planen.
Sie sagten,
im Normalfall ein bis drei Monate.
Ich dachte: "Nein."
Es ist megacool,
dass es so schnell ging.
Noch ist Pedro nichtsahnend
bei Verwandten in Venezuela.
Kein Internet.
Es ist immer die Frage,
ob es geht oder nicht.
* Klingelton *
(Verzerrt) Hoi.
- Hoi.
Funktioniert's? Yeah.
Du solltest deine Zeit
dort geniessen,
weil ...
... wir haben das Visum.
No way!
* Fröhliche Klänge *
Kannst du es glauben?
Ich bin so überrascht.
Ich hatte recht, als ich sagte,
wenn wir sehr viel Glück haben,
kommt es an Weihnachten.
Unglaublich.
In der nächsten Folge
von "Hin und weg":
Andrea und Pedro im Hochzeitsstress.
Heute musst du
einfach immer Ja sagen.
Okay. Ja.
Jonathan schläft gerade.
Ich zeige ihn dir schnell.
Siehst du ihn?
- Jesses Gott.
Mathias Mutter
kennt Jonathan nur virtuell.
Das Heimweh wächst.
Das ist das erste Enkelkind
für meine Mutter.
Äh, ja, das ist recht ... tough.
Und: zu Besuch bei Angies Familie.
Dass der Schweinekopf bei Tom
auf wenig Begeisterung stösst,
kann die Schwiegermutter
nicht verstehen.
Für Angie ist Tom der Richtige,
für mich wäre er nichts.
# Take my hand.
# Together we will be,
forever you and me,
# take my hand.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022